It knows where we are
Ikaris
evening ladies
watch out
who is it
Sorry
Something's happening to earth
we need to find the others I haven't
seen some of them for centuries
you hear that sprite family reunion it's about
time it's a really interesting mix having 10
characters we're a big slightly dysfunctional
family this is what the end of the world looks
like at least we have front row seats well you
know what's never saved the planet you're sarcasm
Sersi she has the power to manipulate mata and
she's had a long-running on-off relationship
with Ikaris how long were you together 5 000
years i guess you can call that long term
Ikaris is the loyal soldier dad that's superman
with the cape and you're shooting laser beams out
of your eyes i don't wear a cape fastest
can assemble anything out of any kind
of technology there were more deviants than
you said well i'm sure that was fun for you
it was athena she's the goddess of war she can
manifest different weapons which was very fun
gilgamesh he's a protector his
specialty is a strong punch
this is makari none of us
has seen it for centuries
sprite can create illusions she's really
sarcastic especially with kingo i would
say kingo is a little self-involved kingo
didn't vista i've directed some things to
droog he's mind control he stands up for what he
believes in and that there shouldn't be violence
don't we don't interfere in their wars and
then there is ajax she's kind of the leader
of the eternals her power is healing this
planet and these people have changed me
these superheroes reflect the world we
live in everybody is unique and special
i think eternals is the most
epic movie that marvel has done
and i really really mean that they're really gonna
see a movie unlike any they've ever seen before
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
eternals trailer video there's a couple of clips
and scenes that they released so we'll break it
all down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs here
and you also probably saw that marvel just
announced that they changed their marvel phase
4 movie schedule i'll explain what's going on with
that at the end of this video too it's not quite
as big a deal as people think that it is if you're
brand new to the channel i do marvel videos every
week so be sure to subscribe to get everything if
you do get a chance to see the movie early please
do not post spoilers on this video just starting
at the beginning of this footage and working
our way through shot by a shot so the scene here
starts with basically Ikaris saving black knight
kit harrington's dane whitman character in the
other eternals if you look in the background
zoom in enhance you can see that sprite is using
her powers to make it look like the other humans
around them in the street disappeared because as
they talk about in that other clip her powers are
illusions just like loki's illusion so he can
make it seem like things disappear even though
it's all just a big trick then Ikaris surprises
them by flying in superman's style and taking
out this deviant and there is a later clip too in
this where they clarify fastos's young son there
is referring to Ikaris when he calls him superman
like he literally calls him superman so i do love
the idea now that dc comics is an actual brand
like they're actually comic books published by a
company named dc comics inside the marvel universe
the main marvel universe if you've watched any of
the arrowverse shows they reference the marvel
characters on the arrowverse shows all the time
like the flash so marvel comics does exist in the
dc universe you also may have noticed here there
are a couple easter eggs in the background
the story that he flies the deviant through
as he's trying to take it out is a tattoo parlor
named prophets which is a bit of a subtle easter
egg just foreshadowing the truth of the eternals
lives their real mission on planet earth like what
are they really here for versus what they think
that they're here for in foreshadowing the big
emergence that's happening during the movie the
threat of this new celestial is going to burst out
of planet earth and completely destroy the planet
as in the eternals are kind of like prophets of
doom for humanity with most of them probably being
unaware of what's actually going on with their
true mission until maybe later in the film then
i love the way that kit harrington's dane whitman
character the black knight basically running
into help at this point in the story based on
what kevin feige has said he doesn't really have
any natural powers or anything like that he still
thinks he's a totally normal person he works at
the british natural history museum in london with
Sersi's character so he probably doesn't really
learn much about his heritage as the black knight
the lineage of his family the ebony blade till
maybe like the end of the movie in the sequels
in which other future marvel movies he appears in
and if they're giving marvel disney plus spin-off
series to all the big marvel phase four movies
like they just announced the shangshi spin-off
series on disney plus for the 10 rings like a 10
rings disney plus series if we're talking about
eternals who would get the spin-off here what
would be the eternals marvel disney plus series
it would probably be kit harrington's black knight
character and i would love to see them do six to
nine episodes of a black knight series but the
other really cool thing here that you may have
noticed in the background is the music so i make
all these game of thrones jokes about how they
have a game of thrones reunion because you have
richard madden's character and kit harrington's
character in a movie together with scenes together
so it's almost like jon snow reuniting with rob
stark for the first time because they never met
each other again during game of thrones rob stark
winds up dying during the red wedding and jon snow
didn't get an opportunity to see him again before
that happened but another layer to this whole game
of thrones reunion that's going on on the screen
you have ramin javadi who did the music for game
of thrones which was fantastic who did the music
for the eternals movie in this eternal theme music
that plays when Ikaris is walking out like doing
his superhero pose like he's going full thor here
just kind of basking in the glory of his takedown
the eternal theme music swells up and it sounds
very game of thrones-esque now obviously it's a
little bit different from game of thrones but if
some of you got some game of thrones flashbacks
when you were hearing this that's why because
it's ramin javadi coming back to do this the funny
needle drop moment here the bus getting ready to
hit him in the deviant was certainly transmuting
it into flowers while dane whitman just craps
his pants in disbelief because apparently at
this point in the film it seems like he doesn't
know anything about their secrets but it's after
this scene that they have that conversation
where Sersi explains their entire backstory
and then talks about thanos avengers infinity war
avengers endgame why they didn't help out in any
of the wars across human history there's also a
longer version of that conversation in the second
clip where they're talking about her relationship
with Ikaris like wait a minute this is your old
boyfriend what's going on here how long were you
together oh you know about 5000 years on and off
again a little bit then they have the clip with
all the different eternals team members clarifying
their powers in a couple new scenes i've already
talked about the powers of the other eternals
characters in my other trailer videos so i'll link
some of those in the description below if you want
to learn more about the other characters i haven't
seen the movie yet but i am supposed to be seeing
it sometime in the next couple of days so if i
get a chance to i will post my non-spoilery review
as soon as possible i think that's going to be
sunday so look out for that most of the reactions
to the movie so far have been very positive
so it does seem like it's pretty solid film
just to explain what's going on with the big
marvel phase 4 movie schedule so you probably
saw the announcement in the last couple of days
marvel delayed pretty much all their marvel phase
4 movies kevin feige actually explained this
at the eternals premiere this is the clip of
him talking about that production shifts and
changes and because we have so many uh slots
we can just shift slots so we're not so all the
marvel slots are the same we're just shifting
the movies coming out and uh and yes strange
has moved six weeks so instead of there being
three months between marvel movies will be
five months between marvel movies and i think
that we can all handle that it's just that all
these new protocols for filming movies and tv
shows because of the virus that causes them to
take much longer to film so basically what marvel
did is just to give themselves the time that they
needed they just bumped all the movies one movie
slot so as kevin feige says all the release dates
that they had for the marvel face before movies
are the same it's just that they bump the movies
that they're releasing on those release dates by
one film so for instance doctor strange multiverse
of madness was going to come out in march right
next to the batman movie so they delayed that to
may when they were originally going to release
thor love and thunder and now thor love and
thunder is coming out in the summer instead of
black panther 2 and so on and so forth domino
effect everything just getting bumped by one
movie slot by a couple months there'll still be a
bunch of marvel stuff happening at the beginning
of the year marvel's doing their version of dc
fandom in a couple weeks there'll be a bunch of
trailers of course i'll do videos for all that
stuff so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss anything i'll do
more eternals bonus videos in the next couple
of weeks as we get ready for the movie my full
post credit scene video full breakdown easter eggs
videos all that stuff will post after the movie
actually comes out in theaters in a couple weeks
way you wait for everything click here for my
brand new spiderman no way home trailer video
hawkeye trailer videos and click here for all my
dc fandom trailers like the batman trailer the
flash movie trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone and i'll see you guys in the next one!